pendant que marco sirote tranquillement
son café du dimanche son téléphone sonne
c'est un agent peut recouvre l'agent lui
annonce qu'il doit 300 $ à son ancienne
compagnie de téléphonie cellulaire
marcoux dans revient il dit à l'agent
que c'est la première fois qu'il a tant
parlé de cette dette
pour toute réponse l'agent aux
imprimantes est une manne âge de le
poursuivre en cours marco méfaits
conversation qu'elle est ébranlée
l'agent peut-il mettre ses menaces à
exécution
at il le droit d'agir comme il l'a fait
non au québec un agent de recouvrement
ne peut pas faire ce qu'il veut d'abord
d' agences de recouvrement aurait dû
faire à relier à marco un avis écrit au
moins cinq jours avant de lui téléphoner
la loi précise qu'un agent ne peux
t'appeler que tu lundi au samedi entre 8
heures et 20 heures
enfin il était interdit à un agent de
recouvrement de menacer de recourir à
des poursuites judiciaires
trois prises donc contre cette agence le
fin mot de l'histoire
une agence de recouvrement a le droit de
vous demander de payer aussi vous avez
des droits